[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
patrick tu avais mais y'a quelqu'un qui
vient de lâcher une bombe
une révélation de fulnek j'ai dû lâcher
une bombe et ne pas lâcher le quai sinon
surnoté castaldi alors hier soir recevez
laury thilleman miss france 2011 qui
vous a fait remarquer cyrille coulon
deviez appeler delphine pendant toute
loi c'est vrai je pensais à delphine
wespiser alors j'ai vérifié justement
pouvoir c'est vrai parce que j'aime pas
quand on vous attaque comme ça donc j'ai
surveillé j'ai regardé j'aime pas quand
on vous attaque alors vous avez jusqu'à
samedi comme ils n'arrêtent pas de
m'attaquer
c'est un crois que c'est honteux depuis
dresser ils sont faits ils ont fait un
pacte qu'elle iv novelli castaldi le mal
est vrai je le sers surprise bataille
quoi ils veulent m'enfoncer je pense et
je le suis là pour vous êtes vraiment à
lui qui demande c'est quoi bah vous
resterez l'année prochaine c'est bien
chez nous ces achats n'ont fait que vous
laissiez voulait venir vous êtes les
bienvenus avec plaisir par contre ce
sera soit moins 50 % d'accord c'est
parti donc j'ai surveillé c'était vrai
donc cyril hanouna remporte le laurier
de la castaldi tu sais quand on donne
aux mauvais prêts non à quelqu'un en
consomme miss france 2011 nous pensaient
qu'à miss france 2012
delphine wespiser et on se demande bien
pourquoi delphine wespiser à webo d'oslo
des liens ouais bah merci
et comme l'avait rebaptisé hapsatou sy
corinne venayre ans baptisé laurie
delphine et saint-raphaël que delphine l
actif à miss france en mx2 en 2011
medelci
delphine et lou reed croit john en sera
tout seul alors il est nourri des mois
que je vais partir
j'ai bien mangé au clac et ultime qui a
forcément un passif entre vous et cette
fameuse delphine regarder le vent
immense voulu métier
[Musique]
yao
elle est géniale de la dore j'adore le
river c'est vrai je pense et miss france
miss france pour moi c'est delphine cdf
qui respire et moi n'y aura jamais
qu'une miss france sa traque toujours
delphine wespiser que vous le vouliez ou
non voilà c'était va ya non non mamie
strauss l'intéressé destine wespiser et
j'ai pas peur de lui dire voilà qui
quitte à choquer d'accord chercheurs
beaucoup de chance oui ça m'a choqué ce
qui se passe bien qu ils vont m'aider
petit mon père sans voix lente et moi
c'est parce que cet accueil n'est pas
très bonne mais vous vous avez fait ça
tout va du chanteur saison place
derrière soi arrêtez de mentir
vous êtes vous êtes mon animateurs
préférés ces médiateurs peu serré au
chômage en belgique
j'adore quand tu le dis la vérité plage
audience en toi voilà moi je vais je
vais pas dire il s'est passé un truc
dans l'avion je vous dirais entre tozeur
et autres tunis et tozeur est le seul
qui m'a défendu voilà c'est benjamin
castaldi rex et ça paye pour ça je
n'oublierai jamais ce que d'arriver à la
droite toujours compter sur moi
les cinq victimes de très graves
accusations voilà direct ou alors c'est
quoi votre émission préférée
actuellement on est sûr préféré
actuellement vraiment préféré number one
alors franchement je regarde pas trop à
tcc que l'intellect valérie bénaïm date
il ya crime à krim enquêtes criminelles
chronique criminelle ça que des trucs
apprend c'est que la télé d'agencés que
la télé sont pas d'accord parce que jean
marchand l'animatrice a vraiment
franchement j'ai adoré cette émission
mais j'adore nous paraît toujours de
cette émission avec beaucoup d'amour
fédération mais c'est vrai vraiment vous
adorez vers le chocolat gates s'est
propagée dans ces que de laver est sûre
ça c'est une preuve d'amour j'espère que
demain il y aura le chocolat gueddar
williams à midi
avec la garantie des états d'or contre
aux pages vraiment l'effort chez leurs
des pros chez williams à midi ses nuits
franchement ce serait je déclare le
chocolat guerre pourquoi version propage
gégory parce que repas gérard oui ils
adorent ça il adore le chocolat williams
souk où il a travaillé chez le joseph
linder des années était avec des fous
quoi est ce qui se passe mais la
lourdeur et sont en train de faire ils
sont de la partie
alors nous vous payons c'est que la télé
les lancements le sujet les termes
employés ses lauriers du collector c'est
de faire la promotion de cette émission
sachez que valérie bénaïm était un petit
peu souffrante elle a fait l'émission
souffrante de jeu peu son émission la
maison grosjean a parlé dans un instant
c'est la grande fierté de ses lutins de
cette rentrée je vous dis a eu très très
peu de fierté
il ya eu çà et l'émission de valérie
bénaïm je déconnais ailleurs c'est pas
cucul la praline c'est pas larmoyant
affecté par le parle je ne suis pas que
tu apprends que je te rassure il arrête
de chanter il va pleuvoir je voulais
dire que c'est un bonheur les souvenirs
excès passés que de la telline si on
réagit pas surtout non mais je le dis
c'est pas une nouvelle machine à laver
week-end donc avec cette machine elle
marchait pas mais maintenant ça va
l'allumer ici c'était pmp ça doit aller
vite
c'est pas parce que tu mets un peignoir
haut bas haut et tu viens dire qu'avec
tout d'abord elle
bah oui je l ai un aussi jeune
franchement beinheim c'est ma préférée
de tout le monde est face à un commando
tout le monde entier non mais des gens
que j'aime bien voilà bah oui non mais
ça irait moshi une personne de chez les
bush je vous préfère je connais personne
là alors très souvent quand on demande
aux fans de touche pas à mon poste qui
est leurs chroniqueurs préférés
la numéro 1 c'est très souvent isabelle
morini-bosc ah ouais normal parce
qu'isabelle est indispensable je trouve
ici bien sûr avancé c'est la maman c'est
la mamie ou l'arrière grand mère qu'on
rêve tous d'avoir et moi si j'adore
isabelle 6 tout parce qu'elle a son
propre humour serait qu'isabelle el jem
en avait racheté copie comique c'est
impossible
voici grand mère c'est faire un bon café
mais pas des bonnes vannes metz et faire
un bon café mais pas des bonnes bonnes
france télé veut garder michel audouy
que la télé comme sur un vélo font une
chaîne la plus spectaculaire ya quoi que
le la distance la hauteur de ses 69
c'est ce qui s'appelle vraiment
s'envoyer en l'air c'est soixante dix
mois plus tôt la litterna moyens en
latin mon prof qui le trouvait que je
faisais trop bruit magazine ou saisine
ou le fric adlane fréquentes klahn le
sam est toujours restée à l'est c'est
vrai j'avais un copain qui semble une
excellente amie qui s'appelait soutif et
les gens adoraient parce qu'il vivait à
me tiens quelqu'un n'a jamais eu pour
une fois le sort avec un soutif
et la superbe moi tu saoules à perdre
mais c'est faire un bon café
mais courir inverse il va alors souvent
me demande comment devenir chronique en
touche pas à mon poste et je réponds qui
servit de ne jamais regarder la télé et
ne pas avoir peur de porter des
déguisements à la confier sont les deux
éléments principaux
mais il ya une condition pour devenir
chronique en tp que j'ai découverte hier
c'est le lauréat de l'émission qui
n'engagent que des chroniqueurs qui ont
les pieds pour hi hi on savait jean
michel maire avait les pieds moisi eh
bien on a découvert qu isabelle avait
les plus beaux pieds la télévision
française
face aux oreilles avec ça fait un choc
la preuve avec ces images des les
spectateurs qui regardaient l'émission
en direct hier qu'ont découvert les
pieds d'isabelle c'est terrible
[Musique]
c'est à dire alors je vais dire la
vérité je vais prendre la départ
d'isabelle encore une fois aller eu un
petit accident de la vie en tunisie
voilà et c'est pour ça que vous avez dû
mettre des pansements le pièce est fiché
dans le fond de leur parler du sauté du
bateau mais ouais c'est ça et lockheed
au carré et on qu'il a il appuie a
percuté une raie manta
il a poliment il embrasse à l'arrêt il a
pris les halles après un ongle ici là
dans la populaire non mais c'est vrai et
vous avez des pieds magnifique non mais
sans équipe
merci allez pour finir ce soir j'ai
encore une fois échanger vos voix j'ai
pris des phrases de cyril maxime
isabelle jean michel et mathieu et j'ai
déposé sur des journalistes des
politiciens ont des personnalités
complètement à l'opposé de vous c'est
donc évidemment le switch je fais un
soin visage que j'expose et 20 minutes
et le corps sur le corps comme l'esc
rebelles mais beaucoup de crème et tout
ça et je m'ennuie c'est dire à peu près
une heure et demie tu fais pas un
peeling de la nuit or vous faites
l'amour combien de fois pardon aucun
parent oui deux fois par semaine vous
faites l'amour sans quatre fois par an
saisi deux fois par semaine que
multiplie machin s'adonne sans katrina
il s'est tu pendant la pub des experts
vous je suis sur wade qui avait là deux
ovnis allez c'est pas compliqué bah vous
au style cinq ans à peu près en dans la
marne en plein été j'ai vu une forme
circulaire passé mais c'est un frisbee
connard
[Musique]